you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game four
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between ananda Carlsen
going into this round both players are
level at one and a half points each and
Anand on the white end in this one
opened with e4 Carlsen replying a5 and
for the first time in this match we see
the right Lopez and to be more exact we
have the Berlin defense with tonight
take c4 and still running further with
this very common line it is like giving
up the bishop pair in exchange for what
exactly well black now has a damaged
Queen side structure black is also on
castled and positive for white here is a
4 to 3 majority on the King side where
is the positive for black well it has to
do with having the bishop pair so one
other detail to note is that this
particular advantage of a 4 to 3
majority on the Queen side eventually
you'd like to advance those pawns and
create a past pun but you certainly need
to be cautious about how exactly you
advance them in the game we saw h3 which
is quite common and a prelude to the g4
advance it's not enough to just
recognize you have a majority and say
I'm going to advance them and eventually
get a past pun doing something very
abrasive like g4 is setting yourself up
for some serious problems
the bishop currently hitting at g4 and
it could be defended but black can hack
away at that point we could hit here
black could defend and you could do
something like this but that's not the
direction to go in for white this is not
the dream Square for the F pawn the F
pawn does not want to be around to watch
over g4 it wants to be up here on f5
where it forms a pawn duo on the fifth
rank one other detail just to emphasize
something here is that g5 if g5 is
played
this is bad not only for this reason
where the pond could be captured but
let's just assume it's it is defended
let's just say the king is on this h2
square to defend this move is still bad
and the reason for that is because the
f5 square is now a hole in the white
king side position and these pieces can
be making use of it and what was once a
perfectly healthy structure on the white
side is no longer so we don't go down
that road h3 first and we get more
development in it's quite tame on the
black side in short order we'll have
King see 8b 6
King b7 and black will have been
successful with artificially castling so
we have that black does get out of the
pin the dark square Bishop scum off
white prepares to now double on the D
file c5 initially I thought was to
vacate c6 for the minor pieces you could
see that in some lines but I believe the
primary function of this move is to
watch over d4 so that you secure an
eventual Bishop e6 position just as the
pawn on h6 is doing so we have white
following up with the doubling on the D
file the bishop place to e6 and now 91
retreating so - so as to get the pawns
in motion get this f4 move in and get
the majority rolling so it's now Knight
g6 attacking the weakness that has well
attacking what is now a weakness the bit
the knight was there to defend but now
now he's not around to defend as easily
he does play the d3 and I'm not so sure
how secure a square this is for the
night one might think well I can kick it
away the night when he does play to d3
he's there to defend and he's there to
attack but what are you doing after c4
well fortunately light still has a good
reply it would be Knight c5 and
this capture of a pond would be quite
temporary at the end of it the pond will
be won back and the big question is what
exactly is this rook on a a doing now
that the position has opened right up
well there's not a good answer to that
and white would be in the driver's seat
in that particular line so we don't have
c4 but rather the more convenient b6
something black wanted to do anyway so I
so - to get the king - b7 and it's
defending c5 92 is played focusing on f4
and this next move is one that will
remind many players of Game one of the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Boris Spassky and Bobby Fischer
move 18 Bishop takes a - quite similar
to the move we saw in Game one of the
1972 Championship where Fischer grabbed
upon on h2 and eventually had that
Bishop trapped with g3 and eventually
lost the game might that same thing
happened here well a similar move was
played b3 and it's quite common to not
make these types of pawn grabs because
of this particular follow up and now
you're finding your bishop trapped
he has no safe squares but there is a
good follow up and the follow up is c4
the only reply hitting the night and
trying to break out this structure the
knight retreats of course if this
captures here the bishop is free to run
away there will be no trapping the
bishop but after night on D 2 c1 the
bishop is hit C takes B C takes B the
bishop is now hit twice and Bishop b1 is
the only safe Square and there's really
not a way to trap him he will get away
by way of
Bishop b4 or Bishop to f5 so Anand with
this variation has clearly given up a
pun but is now in a position to set
these ponds in motion and that's what we
have f4 comes and now can to b7
initially you might think this move is
played to connect rooks it's there to
activate the a8 rook but actually the
primary function of that move believe it
or not is to vacate the c8 square for
the bishop that's a pretty interesting
feature or at least one of the
interesting features of this game for
what to do now after anons Knight c3
well it's actually a very forcing line
the bishop has only one safe Square and
it's f5 and after g4 the only safe
square is c8 the bishop must return home
you can't go to e6 because of a fork and
he clearly cannot play to d7 so he must
return home and if you're just looking
at the game from this point on your
first quick thought might be at least
concerning the bishop black didn't move
the bishop yet but he certainly did
what an interesting journey he had
grabbing down an a2 posting on b1
f5 and then running back home very
interesting sequence of moves we have as
a follow up now
Knight to D 3 F 4 is hit and I I had
thought Knight e 2 would be played it
seemed a bit unnatural to me to obstruct
the rooks view on the D file but
certainly there is another key point to
having the knight on d3 opposed to e2
what exactly does it do different or
what more does it do well it watches
over a 5 and this is important because
now when f5 is played there won't be
Knight takes on e5 if the knight is on e
2 this would be a blunder
so it is after Bishop c8 after he
returns home it's night d3 f5 is not
long off-black now tries to break down
this structure Anand is not going to be
so quick to give up a light square on
the Kings side f5 now comes and black is
getting rocked back white again down
upon but pushing black around Knight b5
another interesting feature of this game
is what we're seeing much a lot of play
on the King side many white pawns
advanced black is also taking part with
some action on the King side we also
have action in the center the rooks
doubled on the D file and the mound is
now with this last move reminding
Carlsen that there is some pressure on
the Queen side so the whole board is
being made use of and there's additional
pressure right around the corner so
first we have Carlsen open up the H file
which gives a new possibility to the hh8
rook and he hops right to it there is an
additional move of a6 and we'll have a
look at these two particular moves on
this move 28 for black the move order
does matter you might think you could
play rook h4 and then on the next move a
6 but that's not necessarily the case
let's have a look after the move played
in the game rook h4 the night does play
- f2 to defend and now if you think you
could play a 6 and chase the night away
to d4 or c3 well keep in mind he has
this additional square d6 after he has
taken the pawn hits the night and after
he runs away d6 is there and the rooks
are they
our d7 is there and the rooks are there
to defend the pun this isn't necessarily
bad for black but it certainly makes the
King position a little bit more
vulnerable I guess you could say maybe
the rooks one day can penetrate on this
7th rank and start to grab some ponds
the material will be won back but keep
in mind that by playing a6 first instead
of rook to h4 this Knight d6 move is no
longer available because after takes
takes and d6 well the rooks keep in mind
our obstructed by the knight on d3 so we
would just have Bishop takes pawn
whereas in the other variation after
rook to h4 the knight is there to defend
g4 and clears the way for the rooks to
eventually support this pawn to advance
to d7 so move order just a quick
instance of or a quick example of how
exactly move order can certainly matter
so it's now knight c6 knight c6 is
played
rook c2 anand now focuses his attention
on the c6 Knight as well as the c7 pawn
a5 I had first thought my first thought
was this with this move is I thought it
was a mouse slip that's what I had said
jokingly during the livestream that I
was doing I was thinking a six will be
the move to try to kick the night away
finally but keep in mind what white can
be doing in reply to the threat on the
night nothing he could ignore it and
focus his sights on c6 if the knight is
taken white is there to recapture and
then some because c6 will fall and white
is in the driver's seat so what about
Bishop d7 well now we could try to kick
away we could try to deflect the bishop
from it's too
offensive the night with a six and after
a couple captures can you come back here
with the bishop well not so fast
Knight d4 is now available the knight is
hit for a third time he's only defended
twice and he cannot be defended for a
third time Knight takes Knight that's
not working
black ends up getting checkmated so what
black can do if this is in fact a line
is after the capture on e6 to not move
the bishop but rather take the knight
allow the bishop to be captured and now
there's still some issue on c6 black is
actually still there to defend the
knight but now comes the night the white
knight into d3 and this is this line I'm
showing you here is certainly being
shown with the help of a computer if
black is now doubling on the H file
there is in a very interesting sacrifice
that could come about on the c6 square
with Knight e5 to follow and at the end
of it all black is giving up the rook
for a pawn but keep in mind the black
King is very active the white King not
so much white grabs this pawn at the end
of this very long-winded variation we
will end up having this position being a
draw the black King will hunt this pawn
down and in the meantime the white king
scoots over and eventually will have the
knight sacrificing itself for the two
remaining black pawns so just a very
interesting line that I came across one
of the many that I came across when
reviewing for this video we did not get
to see those sort of complications we
did not see in this game a six but
rather a five and the intention behind
that is to activate the rook by simply
not even moving it but but by moving the
pawn in front of the rook just as we saw
here on the H file the H we had an h5
move there was
capture and the rook was freed in that
way
well Carlson is trying a similar thing
to activate his Queen rook by getting in
the a for move and now it sees this of
course and plays rook C for stopping the
a for advance there's also some lateral
support to the g4 pawn what now follows
is g6 looking to break down this
structure and this here was another
interesting possibility for Carlsen one
which could have led to two different
imbalanced positions one where White
would have a knight versus three black
pawns or one where white would have two
knights versus a black rook and two
pawns let me show you after Bishop takes
f5 this was not the move that was played
the move that was played was g6 but we
could have had Bishop takes on f5 and
after the recapture takes takes Knight
here and now that's this is the
situation we're in where it's a knight a
white knight versus three black pawns in
balanced position another variant of
that would be after Bishop takes on that
five to take on c6 and in this one we're
entering the night or two nights versus
rook and two pawns we did not go down
either of those roads but an interesting
possibility was this moment right here
after rook c4 to actually capture on f5
instead it was g6 it now comes more
pressure against the night it is
defended and now white tries to kick the
bishop away similar to variation I had
shown already and after the capture on
f6 the recapture the bishop can drop
back and unlike the other ver this one
variation I showed where the knight
played to d4 this night can be captured
successfully
the end of this variation this will not
turn out to be checkmate previously
there was an upon on a sex and it would
have led to mate with both rooks getting
on the seventh and eighth ranks but not
the case here since a six is now
available to the king so an additional
difference between this a six move and a
five move in some lines having now a six
available to that black king so we
wouldn't have Knight d7 here but what
was played is Knight to e4 yet another
interesting point in the game allowing
black to grab another pun and this time
to do so with check that's what we have
rook grabs on g4 with check anand
improves his king position keep in mind
white is now down two points two pawns
but has very active pieces a lot of
pressure on the black position the
knight on c6 pressure on c7 a
centralized knight and a much more
centralized white King not not so much
it's not so harmonious let's say on the
black side Carlson is still needing to
untangle so after King F 2 we had rook
f4 and King to e3 this here was another
interesting opportunity for Carlsen
instead of rook f4 there is rook to d8
available now one might have thought
after King f2 this here is a threat or
in other words to give check to the king
with discovered attack on the rook he is
tactically vulnerable since he's
unprotected rook d8 still is available
allowing this check he could be taken
and after rook takes rook black would
have a very good reply ninety-five
hitting the rook and there's also
discovered attack against the night
there could be a check but after King b8
this is held together by a thread but
it's going to fall apart soon
black will get some material black black
will get some material back and black is
better so rook da was an option at this
moment right here after King to f2 we
could have saw rook d8 but it instead
was rook f4 black is now being attacked
here the white King is more central
Carlsen drops back to f8 and now comes
Knight d4 this is a very forcing line
Knight takes we don't recapture just yet
on d4 we take on c7 with check first
King a6 is available only now do we
recapture Carlsen gets his rook involved
Anand gets out of the way and we're now
we have now met time control here we met
time control at this moment right here
after King takes d4 anons 40th move and
so he gains an additional hour at this
point and this here is Carlson's 40th
move rook to d8 giving check and the
decision here by Anand is King to c3
King to e3 was the other possibility but
I believe the decision to play King to
c3 is based on the following I believe
it is at this point from here on out
that Anand is wanting to achieve a
position where it is a one rook apiece
and just these three pawns a two-to-one
advantage in favor of black but with
just a single pair of rooks on the board
it's a well known and fairly easy draw
to hold especially at this very high
level of play so the white king in other
words wants to stick around near this b3
pond and be prepared for that eventual
simplification of the position so it is
King to c3 black gives a check King 2b
to black gets behind this passed pawn of
course still hitting the night white has
to do something about that you know
is rook c8 and Carson is not so quick to
exchange a pair of rooks if we did have
rook takes rook we have the recapture
and what exactly is black going to do
with the bishop now too many options are
available if the bishop place to be 596
all of a sudden black is close to
getting mated there is a save here
surprisingly enough it would be bishop
c6 it could be taken but now white is in
this very awkward pin not so easy to get
out of white would need some help by the
White King for example King c3 in the
meantime the black pawn will march at
the end of it this seems like it will
still turn out to be a draw so we don't
have that line another interesting one
that came about and we did not have
after rook c8 this capture but instead
black functioning on White's 3rd rank
putting pressure on the b3 pawn and now
comes ruck check King b7 and only then
the capture on EA this is an important
point if you're going with an immediate
capture of the bishop later on this King
could be more influential by playing to
b5 immediately so before capturing the
bishop this rook to 8th move is
essentially decentralizing the king king
b7 is a necessity as otherwise king b5
is met with a knight check and only then
you can pick up the bishop so it is
first King b7 then you grab the bishop
the knight is recaptured and now the
pawn advances again and on is looking
now for a single pair of rooks and just
this situation over here where it's two
pawns versus one and the King's right
nearby their own puns rook g3 interferes
with this idea of white maybe trying to
track down the Jeep on Carlson does not
allow that rook g3 is it rook c3
welcoming and exchange a check is thrown
in that is avoided and now there's
pressure on b3 how to defend that square
or how to defend the pawn well you could
defend it indirectly with King to a to
this pond cannot be captured it will not
be captured with check and that is a
very important detail because just for
that one moment white is able to now
give check himself and then promote
white is winning clearly so king a2 is
an indirect defense of the b3 pun now
follows g5 advancing the past pawn rook
d2 there's not much there's not a great
way really to improve the position of
the rook he has very little choices
these were his three options but d2 is
best since there is now the possibility
to give checks to the black king to
question the black Kings position rook
c5 rook d7 check King c6 and now rook on
e to d8 there is some possibilities to
be giving check the sixth ranked Carlsen
is there to defend and now we have a
check thrown in King b7 and keep in mind
if king c5 if he's going to the fifth
rank here is one way that Anand can
force that situation that I keep
referencing where it's just a single
pair of rooks
and just these three pawns on the board
we could have the pawn promoting and
after it is captured to not take right
away taking right away would allow what
exactly it would allow black to hang on
to the Jeep on the rook could get behind
but black is there to defend
so the important move to insert here is
after the Queen and after it's taken you
give this check on d5 first and only
then take on ei
the difference in the world because
after it is recaptured white is able to
pick up that pond and we enter the
situation White has been striving for
since around to move 40 so we don't have
that particular line instead of the King
playing to the 5th rank its King b7 and
now we have a check thrown in King a six
rook to d5 once again welcoming these
trades if it takes takes we're gonna
have these two pawns come off the board
but one last little trick is thrown in
here by Carlsen first giving a check
kicking the King up to a3 and now
avoiding the rook exchange by playing
rook to e6 it's allowing this pawn to be
captured but it better not be captured
because of b5 and all of a sudden white
is finding themselves in a mating net
with b4 on the horizon and rook a to to
follow there would not be a good reply
for white in this position but Anand is
not going to fall for that even if he is
in time pressure or even if he is under
time pressure which he was around at
this point in the game still needing to
make four more moves to get to that move
60 where he would then gain 15 minutes
with then a thirty second increment so
we did not have rook takes g5 but rather
rook to d8 and now comes g4 only now
does the rook get behind the pawn rook
takes rook gives a check King b7 with
this last movin on has made time control
he is in no hurry to capture on
and is now in a position to not just
grab the pond but also again trade a
pair of rooks so what was played here
finishing up is a for white grabs the
pond a takes being now with this move
making sure that a pair of rooks will
come off this here is finally coming
down to a drawn position there is no way
to successfully advance this pond the
idea here will be to always prevent the
black King from being able to be in
front of the black pond as soon as as
soon as black is forced to have the pond
in front of the king the white rook will
always come behind and give checks to
the black king this is the point right
here where both players actually decided
on a draw they shook hands and we are
still tied up in this World Chess
Championship match but this is without a
doubt the most exciting game of the
match and a really really cool game to
watch
during the livestream and I look forward
as usual to these next games coming up
around 5:00 should be very very
interesting but a very very fighting
type of game we just saw here and again
I'm looking forward to these upcoming
games so that's all for this video as
always I hope you got something out of
it take care bye
[Music]
you